[Applaudissements]
faites tout ce que vous pouvez voir
excusez moi bonjour aujourd'hui ans
collègues j'ai passé une journée avec
moi oui c'est vrai ham en fêtes vous
remercie d'avoir appelé votre prénom
david davina exactement il est à côté il
ya véronique bien entendu leur a dit
merci
alors alors et il paraît que tu as une
passion
il paraît que tu m'aimes bien puisque
j'ai vu ilove baba d'ailleurs je te fais
un gros bisou tu m'embrasses et les
bogdanoff
attention pas sur le menton les adorait
les mecs je crois que vous faire venir
tous les jours soit vous êtes à côté de
moi mon frère vous avez à faire alors la
combinaison s'adresser de torres et
david luiz est exactement alors machine
originale
il parait il paraît la copine m'a dit ta
soeur et ben écoute pour moi c'est ta
copine elle m'a dit que tu avais une
autre passion si je te montre sceptique
le net la cité où les petites lunettes
c'est quoi ta passion harry potter c'est
harry potter est pas que tu es folle
d'harry potter ou oui c'est vrai que
c'est vrai il paraît que voilà ta pas
les moyens parce qu'il ya un truc à
londres
c'est château d'harry potter il paraît
que c'est ton rêve oui que tu fais ce
soir je n'ai rien fait rien ce soir et
toi que tu fais soir je fais rien
c'est vrai eh ben tu sais quoi tu vas
partir tout de suite tu vas partir à
londres va dormir là bas et tu vas aller
au château d'harry potter c'est pour
nous c'est cadeau
j'étais obligée de le faire ce soir
parce que là
dans la rue du parc auto très cher et
merci les cours
ford y va on merci city d'avoir organisé
sa merci d amour merci antoine de caunes
on retrouve demain 19 20 sur canal+
jérôme anthony photos dévoilant
étudiants
là
[Applaudissements]
les en outre mois pensez vous aimez ce
mercato
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]